hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and I'm excited to
be here today I miss streaming I think
the last time I streamed was a week ago
so and I know the last time I streamed I
had mentioned that I would like to do it
like every other day and I definitely
did not do that every other day so
apologies for that really I think what
happened was after my last time that I
streamed shortly after that maybe like
just the reality of everything that's
going on hit me and I just I got super
depressed and had a lot of like anxiety
and stuff so pretty much like just
getting through the the normal week of
working my normal job was about as much
as I could do working my normal job
trying to be there for my kids and my
wife like I just had no energy there
were a couple times when I tried to stay
up late and do a stream and I just sat
at the computer and just couldn't
couldn't do it I couldn't start to
stream just was too exhausted so I'm
feeling pretty good today though have
some good weather but trying to do some
workouts at home hopefully I'll be I'll
be alright but we know some good news so
one piece of good news is the app got
accepted to the Google Play Store so on
the last stream we did we did submit it
to the Google Play Store so we're in so
now I just just brought up the dashboard
here so evidently yesterday I acquired 7
new users and I lost 4 so I'm guessing
is that like a net then of 3 users one
of them is me I do know that some people
downloaded it and then didn't realize
they need to have the neuro City notion
head set
so it's understandable that people would
delete it immediately
but I downloaded on my device it worked
pretty sweet you can see it here it is
like in the app so I'm Google Play I'll
post a link in the chat that way if
anybody wants to check it out you can
actually maybe I should put this link in
the description to the video too if I
remember to do that later on I'll do
that just a reminder - I've been putting
out some tutorial videos on my own
YouTube channel links in the description
please check those out if you want a lot
of times the questions that I get
frequently in the chat I will take those
and turn them into tutorial videos so
that you know if you have any questions
about some of the stuff that I'm doing
on the stream I may have already done a
video to answer it and if you have any
ideas of tutorial videos you'd like for
me to do put them in the stream I keep a
list of all the topics that I want to do
so anytime anybody gives me a topic if
it's something that I think is possible
for me to do I put out on the list and
when I have time I try to go through it
and do some videos alright so see a lot
of people in the chat saying hello hey
everybody thanks for joining me today if
you don't know yet we are going to
submit our app to the Apple App Store
we're going to build it first which more
good news you can actually build using
Expo which we are using Expo you can
build for iOS on a Windows machine I did
not know that earlier today I was on my
macbook and I was gonna go I was gonna
build it on my macbook so it would be
ready for the stream and I was going
through the documentation and realized
that I could just use expo so that's
pretty awesome so that's what we're
gonna do so we're gonna make whatever
changes we need to the code to get this
ready to go we're gonna do a build
similar to what we did last time at this
time we're going to build the type of
file that we need to
send to Apple and then we actually
submit that to the Apple AppStore so
we'll take you through that whole
process I don't know how long this is
going to be remember the last time it
took us like three hours to do the
Google Play Store so I'm hoping so some
of the steps that we had to do then we
won't have to do now so I think we can
do it in way less than three hours but
we'll see how it goes now one thing that
we can't do that I'm slightly worried
about is that we can't actually test on
Windows so we might have to I don't know
my wife has an iPhone if we really need
to test it and don't think it'll work on
an iPhone before you submit
I could probably grab my wife's iPhone
and maybe like download the x-bow app
and just test it on her iPhone first but
other than that I think we should be
good that's the only point of this whole
thing that I think is gonna be a problem
now here's what I had to do before the
stream to get ready for this I needed to
create a developer account with Apple
alright and that is not cheap so it's a
hundred dollars a year to create an
account and I recommend like it said it
could take up to 48 hours for the
account creation process to to be
complete so I'm glad I did it last night
because it could take a while thankfully
though I gotta prove like very quickly I
think it was like less than an hour
later I was approved something like that
so I don't know I guess they just say 48
hours because you know maybe it's
potentially could take that long I don't
know but that's already so that's
definitely you you have to have that you
can't submit to the App Store without
that so you need to do that Google Play
I believe is only like 25 dollars and
that's it it's just a one-time fee so if
you want to start out with putting apps
on an app store and you don't have a lot
of money to start out with definitely
recommend doing it on Android it's
significantly cheaper to do it on
Android let's get started I can see one
thing that we need to do already we took
out the iOS for the platform here last
time because we weren't using iOS but
we're gonna do switch that up to iOS and
support tablet true yep
no reason why we couldn't support tablet
now we have Android we epic we have a
package of version code and permissions
I don't know that we need to do that but
we're gonna we'll scroll through the
documentation I read it beforehand but
we'll go through step by step now
actually let me set my timer I'm gonna
do a 25 minute timer of just going
through the code in this case going
through the documentation after 25
minutes I'm going to go back to the chat
and I'm going to read the comments and
answer questions in the chat I'll try to
keep an eye on it on the chat as well
occasionally just to make sure
everything's going all right in there
try to keep everything positive and
let's scroll down so here we go
installed all right we've already done
this step at Jason there we go let's add
this in our iOS build number and let's
just throw in the same thing that we
have here we'll put it in here and that
looks good 1.0 it looks good I didn't
really matter it's not like not too
serious about building umbers at this
point all right that looks good
and I believe that is the minimum that
we need all right and let's go I'm gonna
split the the terminal here let me push
this top I'm gonna split the terminal up
so we can start we can do Expo start so
we found that on the last dream that you
can't do a build if you haven't actually
started Expo yet so we're running the
expo start there's a new version I
thought we installed the new version
last time
that's weird I like I really thought we
installed the latest version
let's hit the studio install real quick
while that's going we could figure out
our next steps as well I was uh I just
didn't anybody watch last time didn't we
update that I seriously doubt in one
week it's the version is increased that
much but anyway well we'll double check
version numbers and stuff unless I have
the version in the package.json lot
we'll see all right so we have skipped
the Android part for iOS
I need the Apple ID and password which I
have
all right so just like we had our
Android key store last time we're gonna
have a distribution certificate and I'm
just gonna let Expo handle that
looks like we'll need to make a password
for that
we're not gonna worry about pushing to
get notifications right now we'll
probably add those into the app at some
point if we keep going with it so just
kind of make a mental note of that cool
it looks like we're good
in terms of build let's let's double
check now and see if we are on the right
version
all right cool so we did not get the
message that we're out of date so that's
good there must have worked okay so that
is working and I'm gonna double-check
the whoops wrong wrong thing but
double-check the command Expo build iOS
that's it so let's throw that in there
Expo bill : ILS it should work according
to what I've read this should work I'm
still like somewhat amazed that this is
gonna work on Windows now do you have
the access to the Apple count yes I do
have access to that Apple ID password
what
hmm all right let's shout it again like
I'm almost positive that was my correct
username and password let's try it again
yeah you know what on my other screen
I'm gonna check it out
thank you I just got an email from the
app store I'm gonna verify what my login
is does I need to do this anyway
alright this this looks like slogan yeah
so I was able to login to my developer
account here so you can see I'm logged
in so let's uh all right let's try try
it again
I'm gonna show one more thing let me
look back here and see for sure what we
need you need your Apple ID and password
I'm gonna try to log out and see alright
that works
alright me trying one more time maybe
I'm just typing it in wrong so problem
when you try to use like secure
passwords then half a bunch of different
characters in it I guess sometimes it's
hard to type in alright Jesse why go
bats gmail.com alright yeah I'm gonna
copy and paste what I just typed in and
hopefully that'll work hopefully it lets
me maybe it didn't
I guess we could do let's run what
scared if upon that and let's run this
Expo debug true and then we'll throw in
the yarn was it was a built iOS yeah
build iOS it was Expo build iOS
[Music]
authentication to developer portal
failed alright well let's look up this
error then debug mode didn't really give
us anything extra huh alright look up
the air see what we're getting here
can't authenticate it's always good when
get something
hmm what we can try is we could try to
put the password and stuff in a I
believe we have the option to put it in
an environment variable file so let's
try that I'm gonna look at the chat real
quick to see if somebody else has any
ideas
okay I remember seeing in the
documentation somewhere earlier that you
can use environment variables instead so
let me just kind of figure out what the
keys are for that
nobody else I guess I could go back real
quick and see
after entering credentials
we is this it
127 that was what we get right alright
so this is the same error let's let's
turn on that Windows Linux subsystem I
don't know if it actually has to be
running in the background
remember we install that the last time
so there we go we'll run that and
all right well this person said they use
sudo and that helped and they got two
thumbs up and that's the only solution
that I saw any anybody give thumbs up to
which is usually good sign so let's just
try that because that's a very easy
thing to do so let's run sudo Expo build
iOS and now we have the Linux subsystem
up so oh it's not gonna let me do sudo
cuz this is still the yeah okay this is
not I'm not gonna be able to run it from
within there of course I can't do sudo
you know what I could do I could open
this project from as an admin so let's
do that
actually let's let's just try to run it
let's try to run it one more time with
Ubuntu actually running just to see if
that will help
did not help so next up alright here's
the next two steps I'm going to take I'm
gonna try to open this as an
administrator and run it if that doesn't
work I'm gonna try to run it in
PowerShell and see if that works then so
I have this open yeah this one is run as
admin I believe I already have an admin
version of es code running so I'm just
gonna go to open the workspace and my
projects
what can I not find my projects file
this way
area stay focused
today after all that it was the wrong
thing open folder
what it didn't open it no run as
administrator' all right running as
administrator see if this makes a
difference okay
now let's run expose all right on the
power show it is hope I can't do CD I
don't know how to make power show bigger
let's run it as admin just to be sure
the with a
system32 I need to look up PowerShell
commands change directory no that's not
there we go and if I could do what all
right
that's an insane amount of files I did
not need to know all of that
she used to agree where am I in there we
go there we go
I'm sorry about this phone sighs just
like I never used this I don't really
know how to make it bigger
and I'm assuming that I can get to users
directory from here no maybe where my
windows go here and see
okay now from here there we go
users and then Jesse and then projects
and then stay focused yay finally I'm in
here okay now see if this will work Expo
build iOS
[Music]
this is a good sign right whoa all right
we get past that step nice all right it
says all right so it sent me a text
message for the six digit code I have to
put that code in
what developer porterfield authorized
access no I got so close all right I got
farther but for some reason it didn't
work
dang it which I this again
[Music]
you
all right so I got a new code
yeah okay well my timer ran up so let me
go to some questions now and take a few
minutes as a break and can I get back to
it
world's world best tick-tock official
asked if I'll make flutter tutorials
probably you're not gonna make a flutter
tutorial anytime soon
because I just I don't work with flutter
so probably not gonna happen usually the
tutorials I do I use like stuff that I
actually used so that I could like know
what I'm talking about
I have some questions about like what is
the app which it capable of I'll give a
little overview but if you want to know
more check out like the previous the the
previous live streams or on my youtube
channel I go over the the notion neuro
City headset that is the brain computer
and the links in the description to my
channel so you can check that out I go
into a lot more detail but basically
this app just works you put a device on
your head actually this device put this
device on your head and read your
brainwaves specifically we're looking at
the part of the brain that tells us your
level of focus and when your level focus
goes below a certain amount the phone
vibrates and flashes the color red and
then that way it gives you a little
reminder to stay focused
John Jonathan says hi herder I I heard
order helps on energy levels do you have
videos on that like organization of data
time and files because it also absorbs
your energy to have digital disorder and
congratulations well thank you and you
know what I actually don't have a video
on that but I've been thinking about
doing a video on how I do project
management with like a Kanban board so
that that kind of falls into that in
terms of like managing the tasks in a
particular project so I was thinking
about doing that video I wanted to do it
today I don't know if I'll time or not
but I wanted to do that video soon
someone says hey I need a good tech lead
to project manage and build a team on an
application I'm building do you do any
consulting work or know anybody
qualified I can talk to send me a DM on
Twitter or something my links in the
description I don't know that I have
that much time to do it myself but I
could try to get you get you in touch
with somebody
someone asks about what's react native
why is a useful react native lets you
use JavaScript to build native mobile
apps so it's very useful if you know
JavaScript and you don't want to have to
learn two other languages to be able to
build for Android and iOS someone asks
why Expo Expo I think makes it very easy
to work with react native easy to build
and and run locally and test also it's
supposed to be easy to build for iOS
even if you're on Windows although we're
having some issues with it right now and
so that's why I chose it
PGA gaming says love from India man
thank you I appreciate that someone
asked what a brain-computer is I think I
just showed you what the brain the brain
computer looks like and kind of gave a
little description if you want to know
more check out the link in the
description of my youtube channel I do a
whole demo video on the neuro satine
ocean brain computer interface
I'm saying there's a nice discussion
about why you would learn JavaScript in
the chat there someone asked how they
can get the previous material because
this is the first one they saw check out
the videos on the free code camp YouTube
channel the previous videos they'll all
have like the same thumbnail and they'll
all be listed as I believe it's build a
brain computer with react native brain
keep your app with react native all
right I'm gonna go back to the code now
and what I'm gonna do I'm gonna copy
this and see if we can debug what's
happening yep this is it this is exactly
what we're getting mmm probably need to
accept some new agreements and iTunes
Connect
all right let's check this up then and
see it doesn't look like that help for
that person but it's worth the worth a
try looks like it let me get in
agreements see what this is oh there we
go
new agreement yep they all know my
address
wonderful I don't really care cuz like
honestly if somebody wanted to know my
address like it wouldn't be that hard to
find it online I'm sure it's like
publicly available
let's set up tax banking in contact I
don't want to do all that let me do this
on my other screen and you see if I'm
not gonna set up tax forms right now
all right anyway I opened up this page
because we will need this page to
register an app ID or to register our
app once we get it built but I guess
it's worth a try to run this again just
to see if if that really was the case
that I needed to accept that
[Music]
dang
alright so that didn't work alright
let's go to scooter that github issue
see what else people were saying yeah
has access
hmm
hi this interesting
you
so this person said they signed signed
out of the Maine Apple ID logged in with
the ID they're trying to use with Expo
tried to build it and then that worked
because there was an extra step of
clicking allow I guess my MacBook down I
didn't I left it up I meant to bring it
down what I could try to do is be on my
macbook with this account at the same
time just to see if some sort of other
notification comes up I would hope that
I wouldn't be the case she says check
this one out before I do that
TTIP is to me
interesting
actually so setting this with a default
phone number it said it solved it we
could try that
all right so saying if I enter SMS then
select the trusted phone number and then
enter that second code then it works
let's try that that seems like it'll be
pretty easy to test I'm sorry this is so
small let me what the heck
why is it giving me I don't know why
it's giving me a different different
input make power show font bigger
properties
area
yeah you know it let's make just fill up
half the screen alright and okay that is
wrapping yes I do have access to the
apples
I'm just not working
right
too many verification codes have been
sent
[Music]
all right let me let me grab my Mac real
quick we're gonna take a we're gonna
take a break so we take like I don't
know like two minutes or something for
me to get my Mac and it should still be
running so I shouldn't have to like
actually set it up or anything like that
and then I'll come back so I'm pretty
sure I have my my stuff just upstairs I
will be right back
alright so got my macbook one of my kids
just lost a tooth so that's cool alright
I don't know how long it's gonna like
make us wait until we can send another
code hopefully not too long but I'm also
hoping that maybe the one person
mentioned something about the like a
button popping up on their MacBook
saying to accept some I'm hoping that
maybe like a button will pop up instead
of the come on MacBook what are you
doing
my MacBook not working I'm hoping the
button will pop up and then I'll be able
to just click that instead of having to
do the text message for some reason the
MacBook screen just went black
that's crazy
it was fully charged this should not run
out of batteries I don't know if that's
the issue or not but it was fully
charged all right cool
I don't know what's why the screen just
keeps going like there we go okay let me
sign in to my Apple account on my
macbook and see if I'll get some sort of
prompt on there when we try to do this
alright let's run this again see if
anything happens
all right I see what it'll give us now
okay type in SMS now let's select I
guess if I put in one too many messages
again shoot now it did say we could try
putting in whatever the last message was
that we got so I guess I could try that
it's worth a shot
did we get Oh Kevin's back in here Kevin
I got it I got it
butyou from the channel man I don't
understand sometimes Kevin comes in and
he talks normal and sometimes he just
spams the channel I don't under I can't
tell you had to feast like serious or
just mess it around all the time all
right
okay so let's let me try to just enter
the last one I have I don't really think
this will work but it's worth a try
okay my last code zero three one seven
three two nope
let's see
John Johnson says Jessie do you know how
to recover Apple ID I don't think I need
to recover the Apple ID at this point
like I got I have the right ID and
password the problem is with the text
messaging so it looked like a lot of
other people were having the same issue
and someone was able to fix it by
requesting a second text message and
that seemed to fix it
looking for Lemon says try entering the
spaceship 2fa thing yeah actually that's
a good idea
to enter it like that maybe it'll it'll
let it come in so I'll try that let me
see oh I know what I was gonna do I want
to see if I can if there's like some way
to reset it in terms of my like in my
Apple account let's see if I could we're
good absolute connect
no that's not I'm not seeing anything
there's a users an access panel but that
is not
alright let's pull this over let's see
if there's gonna be a spot where I might
be able to do something I think it'll be
this place so right now
but there is more to this game there we
go
count holder admin and finance developer
oh yeah I don't think this is gonna be
it now
oh well keys
I mean it seems like the f-sport connect
API would be good but I don't think that
that's what Expo uses so it's not
necessarily gonna help us in this case
no so I think I copied and pasted what I
needed no it's not gonna yeah it's not
gonna come up too much okay so let's try
the that two-factor authentication thing
let me find where it's at I believe it
was in the dock here
and
maybe it wasn't in these dogs maybe it
was in one of the I don't want to add it
right
I was yeah maybe it was just in one of
the one of these oh there we go
let's read this is the actual issue on
fast lane which is what we're trying to
use to get the to get the app there so
make sure to see what they're what
they're saying about it
all right let's see this is this is all
pretty recently this one was twenty
three days ago
we'll be cool is if I could at least
temporarily turn off two-factor
authentication
interesting somebody saying that they
got it to work by changing the password
and then signing out of all their
devices
all right so they have a PR that's
supposed to fix it but it's still open
not surprising I assumed it was still
okay
Oh interesting they get to this point
they type SMS it'll ask at this point
and then they enter in the code that
they received earlier we didn't try that
yet let's try that
oh that actually sent a new code see
all right there we go there's the second
one for eight two six four three four
three two three two double checking that
come on yes yes yes it was working sweet
okay
let Expo handle the process yes dude
only took us an hour we finally logged
in
the expo handle the pros i'm just-just
if you're not if you can't see what's
coming up on the screen there the fonts
still might be a little small I'm just
clicking let X go handle the process to
every option at this point I don't want
to mess anything up and go through that
for us again whoo Wow so we had like
several several issues there while
that's going on was just like recap so
the first issue was we couldn't actually
run this from the Bosch terminal in V s
code we had to run it from PowerShell I
happen to be running power show it as an
administrator I don't know if that makes
a difference or not because I just
skipped right to that cuz I didn't I
didn't want to mess with with running it
normally but it did work with power show
as an admin then once we we got in there
and we could actually login to Apple
let's see what was it can login to Apple
and then the issue was with the text
messages so there is a bug with Fastlane
the Fastlane package and there's a fix
for it that has not been merged yet on
github so currently right now it will
send a text message but the first one it
says it does not work you have to
request a second one by typing SMS
instead of the code you get then it
sends a second one after you specify
what number to send it to the second one
is the one that works so if anybody's
trying to launch to the the App Store
using Fastlane
keep that in mind hopefully it looks
like that that pool request has been out
for like 15 days and it still hasn't
been merged yet so hopefully it gets in
there at some point soon I don't know
know what fastly needs to be honest if
it's a company that has this or if it's
just like the community runs it if it's
just the community like that totally
explains why it hasn't been merged yet
you know if nobody is actually like
getting paid to keep that up sometimes
it's difficult but all right that's cool
the build is in progress and we can
monitor it here at this URL let's see
let's copy and paste that once our build
is ready
oh sweet is it finished nice he's
finished
very cool okay so our build is finished
let's go back to our documentation wait
for the build to finish and
[Music]
build your project which is simulator
flagged and download the time all and
given which we can't we can't simulate
it on this device so test the device
field with Apple test flight download
the file to your local machine upload
the app to test flight which I don't
know what Tesla is
oh is this an app store thing beta
testing made simple with Tesla I guess I
can't do it here
do we have this here you have this URL
here which that has our build
hey we could
if I could download this and test it
all right I can take 10 to 15 minutes to
build loads
let's check out our thought I had this
open somewhere already uploading apps
yeah uploading apps to the App Store if
you choose to upload your iOS app to
test flight oh we could just do Expo
uploaded iOS
all right let's do this that feature
works on Mac OS only all right so it
looks like I can't do that manually
uploading looks like I won't be able to
do this
all right so it looks like I have to use
this is this is somewhat misleading that
I can build for iOS on the on Windows
but I can't submit is this correct does
anybody have experience with this this
seems like very odd submit your I asked
apps on Windows system 2017 it's too old
I'm gonna check for anything in the past
year let's make this bigger how to
submit your app to the App Store
hmm all right so this is Microsoft's
all right this is the first the first
time it has to be I don't think that's
going to help I think that's the same
same problem we have right now
yeah that's not using windows I so I
guess what I have to do is let's switch
this over to I can do
I'm gonna see if I can hop onto this
stream on my macbook I don't I usually
don't stream from my macbook because the
quality is is not great but I'd rather
you be able to see what's going on
it's
all right let's see let me I'm gonna
briefly stop streaming here and then
pick up my stream on my other computer I
don't know I've never tried this before
but we'll see how it goes maybe it'll
work I have already downloaded this I
don't think I'll need to do anything
with the code so I think we're fine
there but just in case I've already
downloaded the repo I'm gonna stop sure
all right let's see all right can you
all you'll see me or hear me let me know
if you can hear me I think you can see
me right now I'm gonna try to shrink
this window down haha sweet so evidently
I can switch devices in the middle of
the stream and it'll keep the stream
going that's pretty sweet
I need to figure out how to get this
window to fit
all right that's pretty close close
enough all right let's go to my Apple
Apple Developer Program and it's also
good at expo dot IO so I'll sign in to
my Expo account and then we'll be able
to download we should be able to
download the file that that we just
created and oh you know what let me what
was that thing that they said it was
some sort of thing that I needed to get
from the App Store the transporter yeah
download transporter from the App Store
okay so I do want to get into here and
also my good soaking up the app store
and get transporter hopefully that's not
a large install I don't want to enroll I
want to login see if it'll let me login
not this again two-factor awful done
eight four five nine to five cool sure
can trust it what's up App Store nice
transporter is here let's check out expo
i hope this dream isn't lagging too much
usually when i try to do stuff on my
macbook one and stream it does not work
another code alright so here's another
tip when you're doing anything with the
app store make sure you have your your
phone ready because you were gonna get a
million text message or sweet so we can
add the app this is the one we want
stay focused let's download it I will
say the build for iOS took significantly
less time than the Android build
downloads
nice seems really small it's nice there
it is put it in our cool
all right so it's gonna do its thing and
examine this and then at some point the
button will come up to say deliver no
suitable application records were found
verify your bundle identifier called
just USA focus is correct let's read it
again
I shouldn't have clicked off of that
error I should have looked it up right
away okay
let me let me look I'm gonna look this
up on my other screen real quick just as
I got more space over here let's see
there we go it the auto-complete came up
pretty quick so I think this is a common
problem I see it on Stack Overflow
all right for somebody it just seems
like iTunes connects click on my plus
sign do that fill out all the info
choose your bundle ID figure out your
uploading now maybe I have to do this
maybe there's a step I have to do first
let's go to I know I I know it's already
there
okay actually it looks like let me
switch back I think this this actually
is working I just need to do a step now
in the AppStore connect so I'm gonna
switch back
I let me know let me know if you can
hear me or you can see anything
happening seems like I'm back alright so
you can see like before when I tried to
add an app this screen did not come up
and now it actually has my my bundle so
you see like this stuff so using the
expose CLI to upload said it would it
would need this stuff anyway
so now it just seems like obviously like
I'm doing the manual thing so connect to
slate actually I wonder now it's saying
let me double-check I didn't see a test
flight option
yeah it doesn't say tes late alright
just double-checking them in the right
place I think this is the right place so
this is gonna be ILS
stay focused primary language is going
to be English although there's not
really many words than the whole app the
SKU
a unique ID for your app store that is
not visible in the app I don't know how
to do this store SKU will just generate
one how to get the SKU number
I
alrights it seems like we need you to
make up whatever you want so let's let's
do that let's go let's just say stay
focus though one user access what's this
you can limit which users see this app
and the fulcrum I'm sorry if that made a
big noise I accidentally hit my
microphone it seemed like full access is
cool let's create Suites privacy policy
URL oh you know we made that URL in the
last video let's see if we can grab that
from our our Google privacy policy yeah
I don't want the other one I want the
share copy link there we go alright cool
minimize that there we go subtitle
I'm enough
subtitles option I'm not gonna put it I
can't think of one right now all right
there we go no age rating category
primary one I would say is productivity
I don't know what secondary is maybe
it's optional I'm not gonna put it save
that so it saves pricing and
availability we think should I charge 20
bucks for this it's gonna be free I'm
not gonna charge anything I don't think
I can charge anyway because I didn't
fill out all my all my stuff somebody
said I'm we're losing the video I don't
know losing the video
I'm sorry I haven't been keeping up that
well with the with the channel or with
the chat here for the stream cool price
free all countries a region that looks
good save that prepare for submission
need to create let's see app just see if
we can find a generator is this the one
that we used before
I think this was it
and we heard yeah this was it it was
super easy to generate all the the ones
that we needed and we used which one's
did we use this one yeah use these two
cool
oh I already have them maybe I already
have them I just didn't realize it
fairly downloads there we go
I mean I want it again I thought back to
editing device there we go
I found the site is not how they I think
they want like better images
who's the other one this might have been
what I already have let's see
yeah that looks like what I have let's
just shut a shredder upload what I have
mm-hmm dimensions are wrong
looks like I'm left to go with some sort
of other I'm so screenshot designer
I don't know login
hello there's a tornado warning in my
area that's crazy just came up on my
phone we usually don't get tornadoes
here fast lane automates that let me get
rid of some of these windows and start
over so this is definitely not making it
the right dimensions what dimensions do
I need it's only 12 42 by 2688
saying fastly should automate all that
and get rid of some of this stuff here
I don't think I can do this on Windows
screenshots there we go
I don't know if I want to install all
this stuff right now
already coming up on almost two hours
for the stream I think I want to maybe
try to get the screenshots the same ones
come up and we tried this before I
didn't want to do it but let's give it a
shot
there we go I was fine that looks good
absolutely URL
did that download not look at you
app is not like it there we go
someone's that someone's fighting behind
you yeah it's probably my kids so well
for one thing it is raining so hard it
looks like there's a waterfall outside
my house coming off my roof it's it's
really crazy there's a tornado warning
my kids are running upstairs they're
probably like looking out the window and
are all excited by the storm actually if
the internet cuts out and the video cuts
out you know what happened because it's
storming it's really crazy so yeah
things are pretty crazy hey the app
screenshots are downloading let's open
this up see what we got all right cool
we got a lot of screenshots so that's
pretty sweet
extract okay all right so let's go back
here and see if we can get these apps
screen it's it's let's pick actually
which size I needed 6.5 inch right I
want that one at least 65 there we go
let's just throw in a bunch of them
right
five-five whoops I didn't mean to click
that
okay all right
looks good
promotional text I'm just gonna grab
what I had from Google and put it in
here oops
I guess not I guess I'll put it in here
promotional text there we go see support
URL I don't have one do I need one
marketing you out I don't have one
looks like support URL is gonna be
necessary I guess I could do Jessi
waggle calm let's see
alright transfer your app that's what
I'm gonna try to do this again and add
the app see if it'll take it this time
I'm doing that on my other machine icon
choose a file for the App Store icon
let's use the one that we generated is
that OS we gotta go in here uses
projects stay focused and assets let's
use that one
[Music]
is let's say no sign it required and
attachment for what okay yay it works
I'm gonna hit deliver
so see if y'all can see this probably
not anyway it just says it's delivering
to the App Store now so basically if you
remember beforehand it was saying that
it didn't match like the build ID didn't
match or something like that well we had
to do this stuff on this end before we
could upload it in there so
automatically release that and let's hit
save here see we're not ready yet
certainly because we didn't actually
upload it so we are uploading the build
now I assume that once the build is
uploaded then we'll actually see it here
so the upload is happening
I don't know how long it's supposed to
take to do the upload it did say
something about like make sure you're
connected to a power source while you do
this I don't have my plug down here so
I'm not gonna connect to a power source
while I do that but I can go back and I
answer some questions here in the chat
while we're waiting for that to upload
seems like that's the last thing we need
to do anyway is do the upload and then
we I believe we've done everything else
that's required yeah so we need to
upload and then submit for review so I'm
gonna scroll up and try to figure out
where I left off in the chat it's been a
while let's see no I think I found it
Jonah Jonah 10 says hey Jesse if you
don't get it by the if you don't get to
do the time management video today what
is the rain check because it is taking
lots of time indeed
let's hope uh-huh yeah I don't know when
I'll do it I mean I'll try to get to it
at some point this week I suppose
Abdullah says hi how are you how many
people are here I'm doing alright
finally got things to work so there's a
little bit of a struggle but it's
working and believe it or not this is
still way faster than the Android build
and deploy so it looks like we're 37% of
the way through with the app upload so
now 40% I think it's gonna happen pretty
quick I'm assuming we'll see it on this
screen maybe I'll have to refresh but it
seems like we'll see it Hey look here's
the test light thing cool now I see that
what's new in Tesla
oh cool we might get to see it here and
run a test that'll be sweet let's we
should do that all right
Oh abdullah ax asked as well how many
people are on here actually right now
there's only 56 but seemed like we had a
lot more at some point great we had
my computer froze for a second there
hopefully it didn't mess up the video
too much yeah we had at one point a
hundred and ninety fewers at a time so
that's pretty sweet but right now right
now we're 52 yeah I'm I figured we lose
a lot of viewers because we had a lot of
trouble sweet
so he said it was delivered so let me
refresh this and see if we actually have
oh is this the one that said something
said that it might take a little out
let's see the process can take a few
minutes and check the status you have
submission test flight click test right
under your current builds all right well
I'll keep refreshing here every so often
and ok there's a build processing right
now so I'll go back to the chat
hopefully before I get through all the
questions that'll be ready and we can
run the test flight that'll be cool I've
never even seen that YouTube saying that
the stream health is going bad I hope my
internet is not cutting out because of
the storm oh well I'm gonna keep going
do what I can
am i okay
Sode I bun sorry if I'm mispronouncing
the name says how many years did it take
to learn coding I'd say like it was a
couple years before I started to get
like really good at coding now I was
like I was trying to do a lot at the
time so I wasn't dedicated entirely to
coding the entire time so when I first
started out like getting paid to code I
was also writing content so I was like a
ghostwriter for blogs I was the only
search engine optimization work like
minor image editing stuff so there was I
was more of like like a multi-purpose
like media marketing type of person
right so once I really started coding
full time I leveled up very quickly so
for me it was a couple years of coding
and doing other things at the same time
so if somebody could dedicate all their
time to learning how to code they could
probably get pretty good you know much
more quickly
see
Jonathan asks someday can you talk about
hardware installation of devices and
streaming internet connections revisited
I probably could talk about hardware and
stuff I don't know well I'd have to
think about it what what kind of like in
particular kind of like what what type
of stuff would you want to know about I
never really thought about doing
hardware
see Kevin and I believe this is a
different Kevin than the one Kevin that
kept spamming the channel so Kevin says
which which platform do you deal with
web and mobile mainly so and that's via
like reacted reactant Aidid will
question from it is emerald
I'm loving this I'm not really good in
react but I would love to learn so can I
learn from you yeah sure I mean ask any
questions you want during the stream
hopefully you learned something for this
particular stream we're not really doing
much react like we build everything in
react but this is more of like going
through the process the AppStore process
I actually I really hope that I could
save somebody some time if they're
trying to do a a build and stuff for the
app store because we ran into some
issues that that basically cost us a
whole hour and it really shouldn't of it
should have been like done in five
minutes but it took an hour so if
somebody sees this and is able to save
an hour or work because of it then it'll
definitely be worth it
Jonathan asks how did he grab the
privacy policy so on the last stream I
found the privacy policy generator and
just used that and then saved it to my
Google Docs and so then I just grabbed a
sharing link from the Google Google Docs
and put it in there so then I went in
this dream and just clicked the link to
that same Google Doc and morandi er
mentioned that the test flight link is
at the top left which I see I saw it
eventually but thank you for pointing
that out I totally missed it at first
from Trimboli kik says it's harder to
upload the app than make the app he
might be right I mean technically it did
take us longer in terms of hours like to
make the app but yeah it's it seems like
it's gonna be when when like everything
is all said and done that may end up
being close to six hours sweets we got
some progress we got the logo this is
still processing nice it's here can I
actually do something with it
so we'll it will test flight run
automatically in order to test the app
you need to install the test flight iOS
app from the App Store and signing you
Shepard oh okay let me install that on
my machine now
wait oh no it's an iOS app from the App
Store might need I might not be able to
do tessellate then because I don't have
an iOS device right now unless I could
use looks like he'd use my wife I could
text it real quick and see if I could
borrow her phone see I go back to some
questions
deep singh says it's 11 where I am and
I'm kind of addicted by the way I guess
that's cool you find it that interesting
I guess so go check out cloud blocks
which would is cloud blocks
Amit Pratap Singh says I haven't stepped
outside in seven days locked up this
stream is the best thing to pay
attention to well thank you well
YouTube's finally telling me that my
stream health is back to being good so
it actually says excellent that's that's
cool
let's see deep sink says I want to learn
JavaScript but I'm 13 yeah you can
definitely learn JavaScript at 13 I've
known some really good programmers that
started out young and we're good like
very good in fact there was a programmer
who I believe was 14 when he started
watching the streams and this was I've
been streaming now for almost three
years so it'll be three years in April
and when I first started streaming like
he started watching and was very very
good and helped me a lot in the project
I was working on and he now he's I guess
like 17 18 somewhere around there and he
already has a job with a company
programming he's very good so yeah don't
don't worry about you know only being 13
years old like get in there and try to
learn as much you can check out the
tutorials on free code campout org
that's that's part of like where I
started out that's why I recommend
everybody start out I think they're
really good and then depending on with
how you like to learn you know check out
some blogs videos like YouTube videos
there are other online tutorials there
are there are actually some good
JavaScript books that are available for
free like the e-book versions are
available for free so there's a whole
series called you don't no js' there's a
series called right I don't think it's a
series I think it's one book called
essential JavaScript
I believe that's what it's called I
think just like a peacock on the cover
or something the like the online cover
but yet you know go for it and start
building whatever you think is cool to
work on okay he says uh all this oh this
was some other advice going free code
can't finish the JavaScript force yeah
so great advice that's same same thing I
was thinking
see lost my place it skipped down on me
blackcats is hello everybody what do you
think about angular I think it was fine
I don't I don't really use angular but
you know I know you know good
programmers that use it and build good
stuff with it so certainly a valid
option deep Singh says what IDE do you
think is the best so ideas integrated
development environment if we want to
consider vs code as an IDE then I really
like using the S code I work with some
people that love Visual Studio I know
people that that really like some other
you know other options but for me I've
been using vs code for a couple years
now and I really like it it works very
well for for JavaScript and typescript
so I recommend that looks like my wife
maybe does not have her phone on her
right now because she didn't respond to
my text message
Micah says some say that there are more
jobs and react and angular yeah I don't
know the numbers for sure it I seem to
see way more job listings for react and
angular but it could be that I'm being
targeted for react jobs because I am a
react developer so I don't I don't
really trust that too much then I don't
know what the real numbers are
see
Jonah's I said oh you you go straight
I'm planning that while I love while I
code love to write both languages yeah I
don't do any ghost writing anymore but I
used to when I always started out as a
freelancer like I just I did whatever I
could because I had I was married I
already had two kids and I needed to pay
the bills so I'd take care of my family
so like whatever I could do for a client
like that had anything to do with
websites I you know I would just do
what mod Randhir says does react native
equal react it does not if you want to
know more about that I actually just did
a video on my youtube channel that lets
you know what the difference between
react and react native is you can check
out that video the link to my channel is
in the description of this video the
short answer is they do they are not the
same they share a lot in common but they
are used for different things like
primarily so if you want to know more
check out that video I think it's less
than 20 minute minutes long and I give
some pretty simple examples of how
they're they're different and how
they're the same
know as some someone is asking people
where they're from yes somebody from
Kenya someone from Turkey someone asked
if we had a video in French I don't
think we have any French language videos
on the free code camp Channel I'm not
sure what are our statuses on subtitles
so apologies about that I really
primarily just speak English I know a
little bit of some other languages but
not nearly enough to do a video and oh
no now we have people speaking in French
in the chat I did take a French class
once I can say a few words in French
okay so earlier somebody mentioned cloud
blocks and I asked what that was and
evidently cloud blocks is home
automation so that's pretty cool
Haroon says it's it's
1108 p.m. in Turkey and I'm gonna sleep
thank you free code Cantonese online
courses see ya Oh
see ya thanks for thanks for hanging in
there and watching it for so long
Eric asked for links where to start
learning react go to free code camp org
and check out the lessons there there's
a whole section on react I think it's a
good intro Jonathan says Jesse thanks
for the lifetime sharing and good luck
thank you appreciate that just going to
get up because it's two hours I usually
move around every hour for five minutes
okay that's that's actually good good
thing to do
all right cool so I got through all the
chat so I guess the my wife still didn't
get back to me about borrowing her phone
to do testing on so evidently this test
flight thing is gonna require me to
download the test flight app on an
iPhone and missing compliance this build
is missing export compliance information
does your app use encryption if yes yes
even if you have only uses standard
encryption within a political operation
okay you know what there was something
about I remember there being some type
of data Wow look at this disclaimer at
the top this feature works properly only
on Mac OS I can't believe I missed that
that would have saved a lot of time
where did I see it maybe it was on the
build it was something about some
special permissions
we're not gonna find it
hmmm I don't see it maybe I have I open
on my other computer
I'm gonna check really quick review
okay no that's different so I don't know
what's exactly what the answer here I
don't think that I use encryption if
you're making use of ATS or making calls
to HTTPS you are required to submit a
year and self-classification reports the
US government may be I am encrypting
alright let's just say yes then does you
have qualify for any of the exemptions
providing category 5 part two of us
export medical years yes this question
if the encryption of your app is yes I
think because it's limited to
authentication digital signature the
decryption of data phone I mean I'm
pretty sure that the endpoints we hit to
get data is HTTPS so that's the
authentication part of it right
you
so it's ready a test is this it
hmm oh maybe I have to do it okay I just
did this obviously policy or was at some
other screen and she policy
there we go
I I don't really know expired bill who's
this ready to submit let's see I'm gonna
get back to the track chat in just a
minute when app store connect users and
testers wonder if I need to do this step
like what if I went back to the App
Store and said I just want to upload
this
Oh do I really need to add these okay so
which one is this twelve point nine inch
display download app screen
okay is this 112 on it I guess I'll just
send them both in all right let's see
you know age rating No here we go all
right cool
Oh copyright name of the person or
entity dance exclusive rights to your
app just be fancy about it put the
middle initial all right now let's see
if I got it does you have contains show
our access third-party content no
there's the app use advertising
identifier Oh actually yeah I think this
was it yes you'll want to check the
following three boxes so on my other
screen I have this attribute of
insulation to a previously served
advertisement actually an action taken
yes there we go
I'm glad I remembered that page and
brought that up cool so my app is
officially submitted and ready for
review now I don't know what's gonna
happen because we didn't test it on an
actual device I wanted to but I didn't
have a device so we'll see what happens
I don't know if it said waiting for
review I don't know if it says how long
it'll take no not really
okay so yeah not sure how long that'll
take
but for now let me go back to the chat
I'm gonna get through the rest of the
questions and then we'll wrap this up
deep Singh says what time is it there
Jessie
it is 426 p.m. so you look tired do I
look tired after all the troubleshooting
I think it just kind of got to me so I I
kind of feel tired Jonathan Jonathan
asks can you emulate Mac on PC I don't
know if I can emulate a Mac you can do
like like a dual boot I believe I mean
you can make they call it like a
hackintosh and run Mac OS on a PC but I
don't know that yeah I could just run
Mac in the PC I thought about maybe if I
could do some sort of remote desktop
thing then I could do stuff on my Mac
while I'm still on here I might look
into that for future streams if I if I
really have to do like iOS stuff deep
Singh says I'm actually surprised on how
long and stressful it is for people to
put up their apps most youtubers out
there show it as a piece of cake yeah it
is it's harder than I thought it would
be as well I think though now that I've
done it this is the first time I ever
did the App Store the Apple App Store
and then the last dream was the first
time I ever did it on the Google Play
Store so having done it once now on each
store I think doing it the second time
would be way faster so you know knowing
what to expect
ahead of time will definitely help so I
think I could do both stores like in
less than an hour now assuming that like
the builds worked and everything
Eric says thanks for the info I will let
all the other guys who are learning to
code with me know that there's a free
code camp website oh yeah awesome yeah
definitely share the info is there
anything else I should know
yeah I would start with free code camps
lessons they have links to a lot of
other resources as well I think it's a
great place to start and you know it's
all completely free but do that there's
enough lessons there that you know you
could learn a lot just from from that
website and then branch out like the
free code camp YouTube channel that you
obviously know about because you're
watching has a ton of great content free
code camp has a forum and blogs and you
know they like they often link to other
content too that's not just free code
camp content so you'll you'll get an
idea for where the good good stuff is
deeps is how much longer is this live
stream gonna go for I'd say just a few
more minutes I'm almost at the end of
the chat here and basically did
everything we need at that point he's
decent my mom wants me to sleep yeah
you'll be just a couple more minutes
we'll be done
neuro City commented and that's who the
company that makes the headset the brain
computer headset says hashtag crushed
thank you I appreciate it took longer
than I and I'd let AJ says if you do the
test flight I'm happy to test on my
device oh that's awesome
yeah I don't know how to I'm not really
sure how to have other people test like
I could add an external tester I've
stored connect users I guess I could add
myself
I guess I've been invited now to test
that's cool
anyway we could Ajay we could talk about
it later too if you want to about what I
need I guess I just need your email to
add you or for external I don't really
know I have to look into that more but
that would be cool
Alexander says I have a little time just
answer me one question how unit testing
and react what is your experience with
unit testing like you know what to be
honest with you I try to do unit testing
and react but I found that I don't I
don't see much value in it if you are
doing and the end tests I think the end
end tests are much more valuable and
really make the unit test kind of
obsolete alright so my internet cut out
completely just a second ago just said
it's lightning there's lightning so cut
out so I'm gonna I'm gonna get off here
let's see deep says it's now 11 31 here
but I'm still happy to be here all right
well I'm gonna I'm gonna finish up cuz I
don't know how much longer my Internet's
gonna gonna work anyway so see y'all
later thanks so much for hanging in here
for this dream and hopefully I'll be
back at some point this week with some
more streams with Jim